hey everyone welcome to simply launch
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning all the sorting and
searching algorithms in one tutorial but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn
now without further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session
at first we'll start with bubble sort
algorithm followed by that we have quick
sort algorithm binary search algorithm
insertion sort linear search algorithm
bfs or breadth first search algorithm
depth first search algorithm bucket sort
algorithm counting sort algorithm and
radix sort algorithm followed by that we
have heapsort algorithm merge sort
selection sort shell sort algorithm and
finally we'll wind up this session by
learning greedy algorithm so all these
algorithms will be explained with
detailed theory along with their
practical implementation i hope you will
have a pleasant learning experience of
all the searching and sorting algorithms
in one tutorial and if you require the
code for all these algorithms please
feel free to let us know in the comment
section below and we will be sending
them off to you as soon as possible now
without further ado let's get started
with the first algorithm over to our
experts
let's try to understand what is a bubble
sort algorithm
the bubble sort algorithm is one of the
fundamental and simplest forms of
algorithm used to sort a collection of
elements the collection of elements can
be either a set of numbers or characters
the control iterates through a sequence
of numeric or character type elements in
the bubble sort algorithm and rearranges
them into ascending or descending order
the bubble sort algorithm rearranges one
element at a time
the bubble sort algorithm is also known
as the sinking algorithm
here we have some random distributed
elements which are 30
10
20
50 and 40 and after performing the
bubbles out algorithm all the elements
are sorted as 10
20 40 and 50.
so how is it done
we will see in the next segment where we
will understand the working
terminologies of bubble sort algorithm
the bubble sort algorithm will not get
implemented on the entire array in one
go instead it compares two adjacent
pairs of elements in an array if the
elements are not in the correct order
then they are swapped so the largest of
the two moves towards the right and this
process continues until the most
significant element or bubble is moved
towards the highest position
after the first process is finished the
search for the next most significant
object starts
and the swapping continues until the
whole array is in correct order this
process is employed when you want to
arrange the elements in ascending order
to understand the logic in a better way
let's go through an example
the example on my screen consists of
five elements according to the bubble
sort algorithm logic we need four
iterations to sort all the elements in
the ascending order or in descending
order the elements in the array are as
follows they are 3 8 4
2 and 12. so in this array the index
begins with 0 and ends with 4
and each time the bubble sort algorithm
goes through the data element list and
it is known as a pass let us analyze the
total number of comparisons required to
sort the array in the correct order
according to the formula
if n is the total number of elements in
an array then the total number of
comparisons needed to sort the entire
array can be calculated by a simple
formula shown on my screen that is n
is equals to n minus 1.
so in this scenario we need 5 minus 1
that is 4 comparisons or passes to sort
the entire array in the first pass there
are 4 steps
let us select the first two elements
that is 3 and 8 according to the
requirement we need to sort this array
in the ascending order hence when we
compare 3 and 8 clearly we get 3 as the
least number so we do not need to swap
them
next is the step two comparing the
second and third elements which are
eight and four
here we need to swap these two elements
because
eight is always greater than four and it
requires placing the elements in the
ascending order
now moving ahead we have step three
moving on to the third and fourth
elements which are eight and two and
here again we need to swap eight with
two because eight is greater than two
and in the step 4 we have we have the
last elements which are 8 and 12. there
is no need to swap because 8 is already
less than 12 so you can see it clearly
so now we enter into pass 2 and in past
2 we need three steps
so the first step in the second pass let
us select the first two elements which
are three and four
no swapping is necessary as they are
already in order
next we have step two
in step two we need to select the
elements two and four as you can see two
is always less than four so there is no
swapping required
next we have step three in step three we
need to compare the elements 4 and 8 and
here we may not need any switching
because 4 is already less than 8. now
here you can see that we are not
comparing 8 and 12 because the last
element is already sorted now we have
come to the last pass
and here there is only one step the step
is to compare the first two elements 2
and 3 and then swap them as 3 is greater
than 2. now the array is finally sorted
and we do not need to do any more
comparisons
after understanding the working process
of the bubble sort algorithm we will see
its pseudo code in this pseudo code
there is a function named as bubble sort
the bubble sort function includes an
array of collections of sortable
elements let us consider n as the length
of the array after that we have to
repeat comparisons for the first element
to the last element of the array if the
first element is greater than its next
consecutive element then we must swap
both the elements and place them
correctly we do not need to switch after
closing this repeated statement and
getting out of the loop this bubble sort
function will end after understanding
the pseudo code of the bubble sort
algorithm let's learn about the
optimized bubble sort algorithm so we
can optimize the algorithms in a loop by
programming it to avoid the comparison
at n minus 1 position after every
iteration
since the nth element is already sorted
in the previous iteration
more generally
more than one element may be placed in
their final position on a single pass
all the elements after the last swap are
sorted in every pass and do not need to
be rechecked optimized bubble sort
algorithm allows skipping over many
elements this results in a worst case
that is 50 improvement in comparison
count and adds little complexity because
of the new code sub sums the swapped
variable
next we will learn variations of the
bubble sort algorithm so there are two
variations of the bubble sort algorithm
they are
odd even sort and cocktail shaker so odd
even sort is a parallel version of
bubble sort for the message passing
system
whereas cocktail shaker is a sort of
bi-directional bubble sort that first
goes from beginning to the end and ends
to the beginning after knowing the
variation of the bubble sort algorithm
now we will see the complexity of bubble
sort algorithm so the best case of the
bubble sort algorithm is big o of n
where n is the number of elements being
sorted and worst and average cases of
the bubble set algorithm are big o of n
into n and lastly the space complexity
of the bubble sort algorithm is big of
one here n is the number of data
elements being sorted let us understand
when this complexity occurs the best
case of bubble sort algorithm is o of n
which occurs at all the data elements in
an array are already sorted here we have
an example with some data elements in an
array which are already sorted that is
10 20 30 40 and 50. next talking about
the average and worst case the worst
case and average case of the bubble set
algorithm is o of n to the power 2 that
is n squared or n into n it occurs when
all the data elements in an array are
reversely sorted again we have an
example that consists of data elements
that are reversely sorted that are 50 40
30 20 and 10 in an array
lastly we have space complexity the
space complexity of bubble sort
algorithm is o of 1 because only one
additional variable is required to
implement bubble sort algorithm that is
temporary variable we came to the last
topic where we will understand four main
applications of bubble sort algorithm
first application of bubble sort
algorithm states that this sorting
technique is used to sort the elements
in a specific order the bubble sort
algorithm uses less storage and is the
second application of bubble sort
algorithm third the real life
application states that the bubble sort
algorithm is used to store the students
based on their height in the line
lastly bubble sort is used to create a
stack pile up the elements based on
their height
after covering all the bubble sort
algorithm topics we will now see a
practical demonstration of bubble sort
algorithm
now on my screen we have an example for
bubble sort algorithm so let us get
started with the code in this code at
the first position we have some header
files that is standard input output
standard library etc
after that we will define the main
function in the main function we will
declare an array with maximum size of
50. so here you can see that we have the
first array variable that size is 50.
size will be defined with declaration
only because we cannot change the array
size in the runtime after that we will
declare 4 variables that is a
b
num and temp
none variable will store the number of
elements of an array after that we will
ask the user how many elements are
required for the array using printf
function
so here is the printf function where we
will be asking the user to enter the
number of elements in an array and the
user will enter the elements and this
will be done using scanf function then
finally we will print all the elements
that the user wants to store in an array
using another printf function
we will have three loops firstly there
will be a loop from the first element to
the last element of the array so this is
the first for loop we need then second
the for loop will use the variable a for
the rotation purpose as we know rotation
equal to number of elements minus 1 so
it will make a loop from index 0 to
number -1
the last loop is used for how many
passes will be required for the
implementation and we already pass
equally to the number of elements minus
number of rotations minus 1. so there is
the loop from index 0 to number minus a
minus 1 then there will be the if
condition stating that if the first
element of an array at index b is
greater than the element at the index b
plus 1 then we will make swap then we
will come out of the loop and we will
print all the array elements after
performing the bubble sort algorithm
now let's quickly execute this program
and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed now let us enter
the number of elements let me choose 5
now let us enter the elements in a
random order
so this was the array input 3 2
4 1 and 5 and here after executing the
bubble sort algorithm we have the sorted
array that is 1 2 3 4 and 5. let's get
started with an introduction to quick
sort a quick sort is highly efficient
sorting algorithm and it is based on
partitioning an array into smaller sub
arrays and then we will sort these two
resulting sub arrays in the same manner
this algorithm is quite efficient for
large size data sets as its average and
worst case complexities are big o of n
square
now let's discuss algorithm of quick
sort
let's say we have an array first we have
to select a pivot
we can select either the first element
or the last or medium or any random
element as pivots
this pivot will dissect the array into
two sub-arrays then we will shift all
smaller elements then the pivot element
to the left
then we will again apply the same
operation for the left sub array and
take pivot like we did for the main
array
we'll perform the same for the right sub
array as well
we have now introduced the quick sort
and its algorithm now let's implement
this algorithm in the code editor
we will start by creating a function
swap
so void swap
int
star
x
comma
and
star
y
equals to
star x
star x is equals to star y
ry is equals to temp
now we will write a function which will
partition this array this function will
take the last element as pivot
and the pivot element at its correct
position in sorted array and places all
smaller elements
to the left of the pivot and all greater
elements to the right of the pivot
so int
partition
and
arr
comma
end
low
comma
and i
so end
pivot
equals to
arr high
now end
i
is equals to
low minus 1.
so for
end
j is equals to low
j less than equals to high minus 1
a plus plus
now if current element is smaller than
the pivot
so if
arr at j
is less than pivot
then we will increment the i
then we will swap
ampersand array
i
comma
ampersand array
at j
and we will swap
ampersand
array at i plus 1
comma
10
array
at high
and then we will return
i plus one
now we will write the main function that
implements quick sort
so void
quick sort
and
arr
bracket
comma and
low
comma and high
so if
low
is less than high
and
pi
is equals to partition
arr comma
low comma
hi
now we will separately sort elements
before partition and after partition
so
quick sort
i minus one
and
quick sort
arr
comma
pi
plus 1
comma hi
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
and
array
and
arr
comma
and
size
and i
so for loop
i is equals to zero
less than size
a plus plus
c out
array
at eye
and
now we will write the main block so end
array
and comma 7
comma 8
i will find the size so int n
is equals to
size of
array
is divided by
size of
array
element at zero
now we will call quick sort
for array a
comma 0
comma
n minus 1
now we will print this
so c out
sorted
array
print
eric
err command
now let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted our array let's get started with
introduction to binary search tree
binary search tree is a set of nodes
organized in such a manner that they all
have the same binary search tree
characteristics
a key and a value is assigned to each
node
the requested key is compared to the
keys in binary search tree
so during search if the key is found
then the corresponding value
will be retrieved
next up
properties of binary search tree
first up
the left sub tree of a node contains
only nodes with keys lesser than the
parent node
next up
the right subtree of a node contains
only nodes that are greater than the
parent node
the left and the right sub tree each
must also be a binary search tree
next let's discuss what are the
operations we can perform on a
binary search tree
first up insertion
last deletion
let's discuss them in detail
first up insertion
we can insert a node in a such a way so
that we obey binary search tree rules
that is the
new node should be either less than the
parent node if it's a it's on the left
subtree or if it's on the right subtree
it should be greater than the parent
node let's execute this in the code
editor
we will start by creating a class for
the binary search tree
so class
pst
and data
and bst pointers
left
comma
right
next we will define some functions
publicly
public
first default constructor
and a parameterized constructor
function to insert the value
and a function to traverse the node
now let's write default constructors
definition
so bst
pst
now let's write the parameterized
constructors definition
bst
and
value
data
is equals to value
and left
is equals to null
and
right
equals to null
now let's write the definition for the
insert function
so bst
bsd
star
root
comma
end
value
now we will check if the tree is empty
or not
so if
root
then we will insert the first node
we will return
new
pst
value
otherwise we will insert the data so if
the value
is greater than
root
data
then
then we have to insert it
in the right subtree
so
root
right
is equals to
insert
right
comma
value
else
else the value should be inserted in the
left
side the root
left
is equal to
insert
root
left
comma value
and then we will return
root
now let's write the traverse function
so void
tst
drivers
psd
start root
if
root
and we will return
otherwise we will first traverse
left side
then we will print the root data
then we will traverse
the right side
root
right
now let's write the main block
so we will start with an empty tree so
bst
b
comma
star root
is equals to
null
root
is equals to
b dot insert
d dot
insert
equals to
root comma 10
b dot insert
gonna be root comma
30
d dot insert
fruit
comma 50
sorry we already use 50 so we will use
60
a dot insert
root
comma
let's use 20
let's try to traverse this
so b dot
traverse
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created and traversed our first binary
search tree
let's get back to slides
at last deletion
we will delete a node following the
binary search tree rules that is the
value of the left subtree should be less
than the parent node and the value of
the right subtree should be greater than
the parent node
let's try these in the code editor
let's start by creating a node
this time we will use structure so
struct
node
star left
comma
star
right
now we will create a utility function to
create a new binary search tree node
so struct
node
star
new
node and
item
star
amp
equals to
product
star
malloc
size of
product
node
next
temp
will be assigned the key
is equals to item
amp
left
equals to null
and
stamp
right
is equals to
null
now let's write
a function to traverse the tree
traverse
product
node star
root
so if
root
is equals to null
traverse
route
left
see out
root
e
traverse
route
right
now let's write a utility function to
insert the new node with the given key
in the binary search tree
so struct
node
star
node
comma
and
key
so if
node
is equals to null
then we will return
new node
key
otherwise
we will recur down the tree so if
e
is less than
the node key
then we will
insert in the left subtree so node
left
is equals to insert
code
left
comma
key
else
node right
would be inserting
now let's return the node
now we have given a non-empty binary
search tree
so we have to return the node with the
minimum key value found in that tray
so
we will start
start
mode
start
men
value
node
corrupt
star mode
node
star
current
is equal to node
so we will loop down to find the
leftmost leaf
so
while
current
and
parents left
is not equals to null
so current
should be equals to
current
return
current
delete
node
product
node star
loop
comma
and
key
if
equals to null
return
root
now if the key to be related is smaller
than the roots key then it lies in the
left subtree so we will check
if
e
less than
root key
then root
left
will be equals to
delete node
root
left key
comma key
now if the key is deleted
is greater than the roots key then it
lies in the right subtree so else
if
e
is greater than root
root
right
is equals to
delete
node
root
right
okay
if
roots
dot left
equals to null
and
root
dot right
is equals to null
and return
else
f
root
left
equals to null
then struct
node star
is equals to
root
right
and free
root
return
temp
else if
roots
right
is equals null
then struct
is equal to root
three
route
return
amp
now note with the two children
get the in order successor
smallest in the right subtree so struct
node
star
temp
is equals to
min value
node
root
right
now we will copy the inorder successors
content to this node so root
is equals to temp
now we will delete the inorder successor
so root
right
first to
delete
node
root
comma
temp
now we will return
route
now let's write the main block
we will start with an empty tray
note star
route
is equals to
null
now root is equals to
insert
root comma
2
root
is equals to insert
root
comma
5
root
is equals to insert
root
comma
3
root
is equals to insert
root
comma 4
root
is equals to
insert
root comma
7
and root
equals to insert
root comma
6
let's try to traverse this so c out
traversal
of
the given
i was
root
now first we will delete a value c out
delete
to
our root is equals to
delete
node
root comma
true
see out
traversal
after
deleting
drivers
route
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
deleted
to and traverse the tree again let's get
started with an introduction to
insertion sort
insertion sort is basically a sorting
algorithm in which each item in the
final sorted array is sorted one at a
time and it is significantly less
efficient than more sophisticated
algorithms like quick sort heap sort or
merge sort on larger data sets
now let's discuss the algorithm of
insertion sort
let's say we have an array
we will start with traversing the array
from index 1 to n minus 1.
while traversing we will compare
elements at the current index to its
predecessor
if the data at the current index is
smaller than its predecessor then we
will compare it with the element before
that
after that we will shift bigger elements
to an index up to make space for swapped
elements
then we will shift the bigger elements
to an index up to make space for the
swapped element and then we will iterate
the same steps again to sort the
complete array
we have now introduced the insertion
sort and its algorithm
now let's implement this algorithm in
the code editor
we will start with creating a function
to sort an array using insertion sort so
void
insertion sort
we will give it argument as end
array arr
comma int
size
we will declare variables and i
comma key
comma j
now
we will create a loop for loop
from i is equals to
1
to i less than size
i plus plus
here we are traversing this array from
index 1 to the size and minus one
so key
is equals to
arr
at i
and j is equals to
i minus 1
now we will move the elements of arr 0
to i minus 1
that are greater than the key to one
position ahead of the current position
so while
j
is greater than equals to
zero
and
arr at j
is greater than key
and we will swap these so a ir
at j plus 1
is equals to a r r
f j
and j will be equals to j minus 1
and then we will assign arr j plus 1.
is equals to key
now we will write a function to print
this array
of size
void
and
array
we will give its argument as end array
and
size size
we will declare end i is equals to zero
for loop
i is equal to zero
i
less than size
i plus plus
c out
arr
ar
bracket eye
and say out
and
now we will write the main block
so end
arr
is equals to
12 comma
11 comma 15 comma
9 comma 6 comma 7
and
size is equals to we will find the size
using size of
so size is equals to
size of
arr
divided by size of
arr at index 0.
now we will print this array without
sorting
so c out
unsorted
array and we will print
array
error comma size
now we will call insertion sort
arr comma size
c out
we will print this
array
sorted
now we will again call print
array
argument as arr comma
size
now let's print this
as you can see our function is working
flawlessly it has sorted this array
now let us try to understand what
exactly is searching
searching in data structure refers to
the process of finding the desired
element in the set of items the selected
item is called the target element any
data structure such as an array linked
list tree or graph can be used for
searching a set of elements
in data structures searching can be
categorized into two types first type is
the sequential search in which we check
the elements in a data list or an array
one by one
in data structures searching can be
categorized into two ways the first type
is a sequential search in which we check
the elements in a data list or an array
one by one
an example for sequential search is
linear search
now let us learn about the next type of
searching approach the next type of
searching approach is the interval
search approach interval search divides
the search in half by repeatedly
targeting the center of the data set the
binary search algorithm can be an
example for interval search
we will go over the binary search
algorithm in detail in our upcoming
video
after understanding the logic of search
and the types of search we will get into
understanding what is linear search
algorithm
the linear search method is a simple
search technique in this type of
searching approach we perform a
sequential search across all objects one
after the other every element is
examined and if there is a match found
then the specific element is returned
otherwise the search will continue until
the data gathering is complete
let us go through an example for better
learning experience on my screen we have
the following elements 50 10 20 30 70 40
90 60 as randomly distributed elements
let us imagine that our target element
is 70.
we found that our target element was 70
using linear search strategy so how does
it work in the next segment we will look
into the working terms of linear search
algorithm the simplest method of
searching the data collection is the
linear search starting from the
beginning of the data set each element
is examined until no match is found the
linear search is completed after the
item has located
in the first stage we compare the first
element that is 50 to the searched
element that is 70. we will go on to the
next element because 50 and 70 are not
matched
we will compare the second element which
is 10 to the search element that is 70
in the next step
and once more there is no match found
then we have the element 30 as the next
comparison and 70 and 30 are not matched
we have the next element that is 20 in
the fourth phase and there is no match
when we compare 20 with 70.
moving on to the following stage we have
the data element 70 and after comparing
70 with the search element there is a
match
we will now have the searching and
display index as 4 and this index
contains the searched element
we now comprehend the pseudo code of the
linear search algorithm after learning
the working terminology of linear search
algorithm
first we have a function called linear
search which has two variables in its
parameters the arrays name which is an
array and the search variable which is
the value then using a follow we must
search for our target variable by
analyzing all the data elements in the
data set with the condition that is the
search item is identical to any sets
value we must return its index value
now we must stop searching once the
searched value has been discovered
then we will close our if and for loop
as well as the linear search function
we will now look into the complexity of
linear search algorithm after
comprehending the pseudo code
the complexity of linear search
algorithm is divided into three
categories the best case which is the
big o of one the average case which is
the big o of capital n and the worst
case scenario which is same as the
average case which is the big o of n
here n is the number of data items to be
sorted let us look into how all these
complexities of linear search algorithm
play out in detail
first we have the best case which is big
o of n as a result the best case
scenario happens when the searched
element is found in the data sets first
block
as a result the search takes a constant
amount of time
here is an example of an array with 50
10 40 20 30 as the elements
now our search element is 50 which is
located in the first location of the
array then there's the typical case of
linear such algorithm which has big o of
n and occurs when the search element is
in the middle of the data set or any
point of the data set with the array
containing the same search element 50 we
can easily see that the element 50 is
present in the center of the array at
the location number 2. finally we have
the worst case which is big o of n which
is same as that of the average case of
the linear search algorithm and happens
when the search element is in the last
block of the data set
as a result of the number of searches
required is proportional to the number
of elements as demonstrated in this
example the search element 50 is found
in the last block of the array index
which is 4.
in the next segment we will look into
some real-world instances of linear
search algorithms according to the first
application of the linear search
algorithm linear search is particularly
efficient when it comes to discovering a
particular string next we will look into
the second application of linear search
algorithm
when a data set has only few elements
linear search is the simplest to
implement
the final real world application of the
linear search algorithm is with the help
of telephone directory you may find out
the name of a person
with the phone number 123
this can be implemented easily using
linear search algorithm now let us have
a look at the linear search algorithm
working in practical demonstration
so on my screen we have an example for
linear search algorithm we have included
three libraries standard input output
standard library and console input
output library
then we have entered the main function
where we have declared an array with
maximum size of 50 elements a counter
variable i a variable named target where
we would store our searched element and
finally num variable where the number of
elements in the array is recorded
then we have a printf function to ask
the user how many items are there in the
array and then we use a scanf function
to allow input from the keyboard so we
have added percentage d format specifier
to the scanf function which is used for
numeric values and num variable then
using a for loop we will try to print
all the items in the array starting with
0 and ending with num variable which is
the last element then we will enter our
search element which we want to find
among all the elements of the array and
as previously said we'll store the found
element in the target variable
following that we will use the for loop
to examine all the elements in the array
then we use the if statement to check
for the element is identical to our
searched element or not
if the element is found we exit the
follow and we will break the keyword
and if the target values location is
less than the number of elements in the
array then we will return the location
otherwise if the value location is
greater than the number of elements in
the array then the search will be
unsuccessful and we won't be able to
find the searched element
now we will compile this code and see
the output
so there you go the code got
successfully compiled now it is asking
for the number of elements in the array
let me give us five elements now let us
enter the elements into the array let us
enter some random elements
now we have entered the five elements
let me provide the searched element as 2
now we have found the target element to
be found in the location 2
that is 0 1 and 2. yeah 2 is located in
the second index location first we'll
build a breadth first search algorithm
which begins by traversing the root node
and then moves on to all the other
nearby nodes the breadth-first search
approach repeats the procedure for all
the nodes until the desired node is
found
the queue data structure is the data
structure that is used for breadth first
search algorithm
for a better understanding we look at an
example of breadth first search
algorithm the blue color indicates that
the note has been already explored while
the pink color indicates that the node
has not been explored yet or visited yet
next we'll have our output
we will use a queue data structure to
keep track of all the nodes visited and
all the nodes that are unvisited
so to begin let's look at the algorithm
as a result we'll have node a which is
added to the output and marked as
visited
we must verify all the unvisited
addition nodes of a that is node b and
node c and add b and c notes to the
output and enqueue to the q according to
the breadth first search algorithm
then we'll look at any node between b
and c
we'll start with node b node d is
unvisited adjacent to node b so we'll
add node d to the output and q and since
node b is now being visited we'll
dequeue it
when it goes to node b the next
unvisited node is node e add node e to
the output and enqueue to the dq once
node d has completed its traversal dq
from the queue
now in the case of node e the addison
node is node c
which is already visited thus we will
dequeue node c from the queue
now that the pointer is pointing to node
c and node f is the next unvisited node
after the node c we will set node f to
output and q
here the pointer leads to node f which
has no unvisited adjacent nodes so we
will dequeue f from the queue and q is
empty so we'll come to the halt here
here's what we got that is a b c d e and
f
after understanding all the theoretical
aspects of bfs algorithm let's look at
the code of bfs algorithm in c
programming language
now we are on the practical mode on my
screen you can see an example for bfs
algorithm we have declared a two
dimensional array with maximum row and
column size of 10 and two arrays the
first one is a square of a maximum size
of 10 and second one which is a visited
that stores the maximum size of 10 as
well some variables n i j and finally we
declared front which is initialized with
0 and rare variables which is
initialized with -1
we perform a loop from index 1 to the
size of an array visited in this
function with the condition that if two
dimensional array of column one and
visited array of index is not one we
initialize variable i to the front of
the queue then one is set as the front
of the queue index of the visited array
and we use the breadth first search
function
with the vertex as the front of the
queue until front is less than or equal
to rare then we enter the main function
where we define the variable x that
stores the graphs vertex and then we use
the printf function to enter the number
of vertex that will be stored in
variable n then we perform loop from
index 1 to queue size and visited array
in which we initialize 0 to the queue
and index 1 to the visited array then
after that we'll enter the graph value
in the form of matrix of two dimensional
array by performing the loop with two
variables
i for the graph rho and j for the graph
column then we print the source node
which is saved in the variable x
then we print the source node which is
saved in the variable x and we call the
breadth first search function or method
which takes a vertex x as parameter and
we print which nodes are reachable by
looping from index 1 to the size of the
visited array if index 1 of the array is
visited otherwise breadth first search
is not possible so this was the
explanation of the program now let's try
to execute and see the output
there you go the program got
successfully compiled and now it's
asking for the input now it is asking
for the number of vertices let's enter
the number of vertices as 3.
now it is asking for us to enter the
input in the form of matrix
so the first row will be
1
2
and 3. so these are the first rows the
next rows will be 2
three
and four
so the last row elements are three four
and five
so we have successfully given all the
three rows of elements now let us select
the source node so the source node would
be two now all the nodes that are
reachable from the source node two are
one two and three
so there you go that's how you implement
the breadth first search algorithm now
let's get started with the introduction
to depth first search
so what is a depth first search
so basically a depth first search is an
algorithm for traversing or searching
the tree or graph data structures the
algorithm starts at the root node
selecting some arbitrary node as the
root node in case of graph and x plots
as far as possible along each branch
before backtracking
so dfs starts with the initial node of
the graph then goes deeper until it
finds the goal nodes or the leaf nodes
or the nodes that have no children that
is the end part here you can see 4 and 7
are the leaf nodes so the depth first
search algorithm runs till the end of
all the nodes that is 8 10 all these are
the
leaf nodes are the last gold nodes
in dfs the backtracking starts once all
the nodes are explored
and the dfs algorithm uses stack data
structure for its traversal now that was
a brief introduction to the dfs
algorithm now for a better understanding
let's go through a practical example
so here we have a graph data structure
with elements a b
c d
e and f so we will be running the dfs
algorithm and we will be traversing
through all the nodes of this particular
graph and the traversal will be recorded
using a stack data structure and we have
two different colors which will be used
to indicate the element's color
so the black color is for the nodes
which are not visited yet and the blue
color will indicate the nodes which are
being traversed already
now this is the stack data structure
that we will be using for the traversal
and we have another part which declares
or which gives out the output of the
traversal of the nodes of this
particular graph
now we will begin with the first one
that is a now followed by that we will
move ahead to b
then after b we will go through d
then after d we have e next we have c
and last we have f
so that's how we traverse through the
graph using the dfs algorithm
now for a little more understanding
let's go through a practical example
where we will be executing a program for
implementing the dfs algorithm
so this particular program on my screen
is an example for dfs algorithm so here
we have the structure node
so followed by that we have also the
methods which will create the edge
and which will also print the graph
elements and finally we have the main
class now don't worry about the code
this particular code segment or the
complete code document will be added in
the description box below and you can
have access to it and try to run it on
your local system and have a better
learning experience now without further
ado let's try to run this program and
get the output and see how the dfs
algorithm gets implemented and traverses
through the graph
there you go the program got
successfully executed and we had the
graph elements that is 0 1 and 2
and 3 so it has visited all the elements
that is 2 3 1 and 0 according to the
stack data structure and we have found
the output over here what exactly is a
bucket sort algorithm
so the bucket sort algorithm divides the
unsorted array into several groups known
as buckets so each bucket is sorted
using any suitable sorting algorithm or
recursively applying the same packet
sort algorithm
i know it it's a little complicated to
understand so let's go through an
example
so on my screen we have an example of an
array consisting of numerical elements
that is 12 6 37 29 11 35 21 and 22
now we will create some buckets with
different ranges
so here we have different buckets
ranging from 0 to 7
8 to 15 16 to 23 24 to 31 and finally
the last bucket with range 32 to 39
so 6 will be stored in the first packet
followed by that 11 and 12 will be
stored in the second bucket followed by
that we have 21 and 22 stored in the
third bucket followed by that we have 29
in the fourth bucket and finally the
last two elements which are 37 and 35
stored in the last bucket
in the next stage all the elements are
sorted according to an order that might
be ascending or descending in our case
we have the ascending order so the final
result will be 6 11 12 21 22 29 35 and
37
so this is how the bucket sort algorithm
works in real time now the next topic
that is working off a bucket sort
algorithm in a detailed way
so now we know the briefing of a bucket
showed algorithm now let's learn the
working of packet sort algorithm in
depth
suppose we have an array consisting of
decimal values of floating values as the
input so the first element is 0.47
next we have 0.39 0.23
0.55
0.29 0.41
0.59 and finally 0.31
then we will create an array of size 10
and store 0 in each block and each block
of an array is used as a bucket for
sorting the elements
next we have step 2
insert the elements into buckets from
the array and all elements are inserted
as per the range of the bucket
packets ranging from 0 to 1
1 to 2
2 to 3 up to n minus 1 to n here n is
the number of elements in an array so
for our example 0.23 will be multiplied
by 10
which is the size of an array and that
gives us 2.3 approximately equal to 2 so
finally we will insert 0.23 into the
bucket number 2.
in exact we will insert other elements
into other respective buckets
followed by that we have step three
elements of each bucket are sorted using
the stable sorting algorithms
and finally the step 4 in step 4 all the
sorted elements of each bucket will be
gathered and represented in the form of
an array as sudo code is an informal
programming description that does not
require any strict programming language
syntax similarly we will understand it
effortlessly so in the pseudo code first
we will create n empty packets
next we will insert all the array
elements into buckets by multiplying the
size of an array we have to keep doing
this for every array element as we
understood this in working of the bucket
sort algorithm after that we have to
sort individual buckets using insertion
sort and finally we will concatenate all
the sorted buckets next we will learn
about the complexities of bucket sort
algorithm
first we will see about time complexity
so talking about the time complexity we
usually have three cases to summarize
the time complexity so first we have the
best case
so that the best case is o of n plus k
next we have the average case that is o
of n into n and finally we have the
worst case that is o of n
here n is the total number of elements
to be sorted and k is the number of
buckets
so let us understand all the three cases
one by one so first we have the best
case
so the best case occurs when all the
elements are uniformly distributed in
the bucket with an equal number of
elements in each bucket if insertion
sort is used to sort the bucket sort
algorithm then overall time complexity
is o of n plus k
o of n complexity is for making the
buckets and of k complexity is for
sorting all the elements after
understanding the best case now we will
see how the worst case occurs in the
bucket sort algorithm
the worst case occurs when there are
elements of close range in the array
they are likely to be placed in the same
bucket
it makes the complexity depend on the
sorting algorithm used to sort the
elements of the buckets complexity
becomes worse when all the elements are
in reverse order and if insertion sort
is used for sorting then time complexity
becomes o of n into n
and lastly
we will learn how the average case
occurs in a bucket sort algorithm the
average case occurs when the elements
are randomly distributed in the array it
occurs even when the elements are
distributed in uniform way bucket sorts
run at the linear time the average case
holds true until the sum of bucket sort
sizes is linear and in the total number
of elements
next we will see about the space
complexity
so the space complexity of all the
buckets algorithms is o of n plus k
lastly we have stability so talking
about stability so yes the bucket sort
algorithm is stable
after understanding the complexity of
packet sort algorithm now we will
compare the bucket sort algorithm with
other algorithms
so first we will compare the counting
sort algorithm
bucket sort can be worked as a
generalization of counting sort
algorithm
and if each bucket has size 1 then the
bucket sort degenerates to counting 0.
the variable size of buckets or
algorithm allows it to use o of n memory
instead of o of m memory where m stands
for the distinct value that gives
counting sort o of n plus 1
worst case behavior
next we will compare the bucket sour
algorithm with quick sort
bucket sort with two buckets is a
practical version of the quick sort
where the pivot value always selects the
median value of the value range another
meaning of choosing the preview in quick
sort such as a randomly selected pivot
makes it more resistant to clustering it
in the input distribution
after that we have the merge sort
the n-way merge sort algorithm starts by
distributing the list into n-sub-list
and sorting each one then the sub lists
created by merge sort have overlapping
ranges and cannot be recombined by a
simple concatenation bucket sort
lastly we have one more sorting
algorithm that is radix sort for
comparison
top down radix sort can be a particular
case of packet sort where both range of
values and the number of buckets has
contained the power of two
this approach can accelerate the scatter
phase since we only need to examine each
element's prefix of bit representation
to determine a bucket
at last we have one more topic to learn
that is the applications of packet sort
algorithm
the bucket sort algorithm consists of
two main applications first by using
bucket set algorithm input is uniformly
distributed on the range and second by
using buckets or algorithm there are
floating point values
now let us go through a practical
demonstration of bucket sort algorithm
now on my screen we have an example for
bucket sort algorithm so we will begin
with the header files followed by that
we will define a function namely buckets
out algo
this particular function is to implement
a bucket sort algorithm in the functions
argument there will be an array namely
arr and a variable num which will store
the number of elements in an array after
that we will define two counter
variables which are i and j and declare
one more array namely array1 with the
same size of an arr array
so this particular second array will be
used for displaying all the elements in
the array 1 we will have a for loop
which will run from index 0 to the
entire size of an array and for this
array we will use the variable i as the
counter variable
we will have another for loop to print
all the repeated numbers with frequency
in an array
we will run another value from index 0
to the last element of both the arrays
and elements of array and array 1 will
assign to arr array
now we will exec from both the loops and
now we will enter into the main function
where we will declare an array namely
array with the size of 100 and two
variables which are num and i
next we will ask the user to enter
several elements of an array using
printf function and now the user will
enter
number of elements and we will scan that
using the scanf function
now we will ask the user to enter the
elements of an array using printf
function and the entered elements will
be scanned using the scanf function
and next we will print a before sorting
and an array after sorting using for
loops by calling the bucket sotilgo
function and in this function we will
pass the name of an array that is an
array and the size of an array that is
num
now
let us try to execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed now let us try to
enter the number of elements that is
five now let us enter all the five
elements
two three
one four and five
so the array before sorting was two
three one and four five
then the array got sorted using packet
sort algorithm and the resultant array
is one two three four and five in
ascending order let's get started with
an introduction to counting sort
accounting sort is a sorting algorithm
that sorts the elements of an array by
counting the number of occurrence of
each unique element in the array the
count is stored in an auxiliary array
and the sorting is done by mapping the
count as an index of that auxiliary
array
now let's discuss the counting sort
algorithm
let's say we have an array
first we will find the largest element
in this array to evaluate the range of
the elements
then we will create a count array to
store the count of element from the
array
then we will update the count arrays
element with a cumulative count
at last we will output each element from
the array followed by decreasing its
count by 1.
we have now introduced the counting sort
and its algorithm
now let's try to implement this
algorithm in the code editor
let's start by creating account sort
function
void
count sort
its argument as int arr
comma int n
we will declare an array
output
size 10
and an array count
again with the size 10
and an integer variable max
is equals to
arr at 0
now we will write a for loop to find the
largest element of this array
so for
i is equals to 1.
i less than n
i plus plus
if
a r at i
is greater than max
then max
will be equals to
arr at i
now we will initialize the count array
with all zeroes so for
and i is equals to zero
to i less than equals to max
plus plus i
count
at i
is equals to zero
now we will store the count of each
element in this array so for loop
and
i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
count
at arr bracket i
is plus plus
now we will write a for loop to store
the cumulative count of each array so 4
and
i is equals to 1
where i is less than equals to max
at i plus plus
count
at i
is equals to
plus equals to
count
at i
minus 1
now we will find the index of each
element of the original array in count
error and place the elements in the
output array
so for
and
i is equals to n
minus 1
i
greater than equals to 0
i minus minus
so output
account
at a r r
i
minus
1
is equals to
a r r
at i
and
then we will decrease count
arr
i
by 1.
now let's write a function to print this
array so void
print array
so end
arr bracket
comma end
and
so for loop
and i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
i
out
handle
now let's write the main block
and
arr
is equals to
we will write the element
now let's find out the size of this
array so end n is equals to
size
of array
divided by
size
of
arrays first element
now we will call the count sort function
arr comma
and
now we will print this array so print
array
arr comma n
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using counting sort
let's get started with an introduction
to radix sort
radix sort is a non-comparative sorting
algorithm it avoids comparison by
creating and distributing elements into
buckets according to their radix
and for elements with more than one
significant digit this bucketing process
is repeated for each digit while
preserving
the ordering of the prior step until all
digits have been considered
now let's discuss radix sort algorithm
let's say we have an array
first we will find the largest element
in the array to decide maximum number of
significant digits we will need to
compare to sort this array
we will go through each significant
place and sort the array one by one
first we will sort the array according
to the units place
then we will sort according to the tens
place
and then we will sort according to
hundreds place and so on till the array
is sorted
we have now introduced the radix sort
and its algorithm now let's implement
this algorithm in the code editor
we will start with the utility function
to get maximum value in this array
so int
get max
with an argument as array arr
comma size
n
we will declare variable int mx is
equals to arr at 0
and we will write a for loop
where
i is equals to 1
to i less than n
at i plus plus
if
arr at i
is greater than mx
then
mx will be equals to arr
at i
and then we will return
the value of mx
now we will write a function to do
counting sort of array arr according to
the digits represented by exponent
so void
sort
at
end arr
comma and
n comma
and
exp
we will declare an integer array output
and
i
comma
account array
of size 10
where all elements are zero
now we will store the count of all the
elements of the array arr
so for loop
i is equals to 0
i less than n
to i plus plus
count
error
at i
divided by
exp
modulus of
10.
plus plus
now we will change count i so that
count i now contain actual position of
this digit in output
so for
i is equals to 1
i less than 10
i plus plus
count
i
plus equals to
count
i minus 1
now we will build the output array
so for loop
at i is equals to n minus 1
to i greater than equals to 0
and i minus minus
output
count
arr
at i
divided by exp
modulus
10
minus 1
is equals to
arr at i
and now
count
arr
at i
divided by exp
modular
10
minus minus
now we will copy the output array of arr
so that arr now contains sorted numbers
according to the current digit
so for
i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
arr
at i
is equals to
output
now let's write the main function that
will sort the arr using radix sort
so void
red x
sort
and arr
comma
and
n
m
is equals to
max
arr comma n
now we will do the counting sort for
every digit note that instead of passing
digit number
exp is passed exp is basically 10 raised
to the power i
where i is current digit number
so
for
exp
is equals to 1
and m divided by
exp
is greater than 0
while
exp
is multiplied equals to
10.
we will do count sort
on arr
of size n
with exp
now let's write a function to print this
array so void
and array
n
for
and i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
layout
array
now let's write the main function
we will declare and arr
bracket
with values
170 comma 45 comma 75
comma
90
comma
802
comma 24
comma 2
comma
66
now we will find out the size of this
array arr
and
is equals to size of
arr
divided by
size of
arr first element
now we will call the radix sort function
and we will print this array
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using radix sort
hey everyone i'm bebo khandelwal and i
welcome you all to simply learn's
youtube channel
in this session we will discuss heapsort
we shall begin our session by
introducing what is a binary heap then
we will discuss the implementation of
the heap sort
after that we will check out various
applications of heap so
finally we will sum up what we have
learnt from this session
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon below so you
never miss an update from simply learn
let's get started with what is a binary
heap
it's a complete binary tree with all
levels completely filled except the last
level
where all leaves are to the left as far
as possible
a binary heap can be either min heap or
maxi
in a min binary heap the elements at
root must be minimum among all elements
present in the binary heap
max binary heap is like min heat where
root must be maximum among all elements
now let's discuss implementation of heap
sort
first
we will start with creating a max heap
of elements present
next up we will remove the elements at
the root and put it at the end of the
array and put the smallest element at
the root
after that we will reduce the height by
1. finally we will repeify the root
element again and repeat the process
from step 2.
now let's try to implement this
algorithm in the code editor we will
start by creating a function to refine a
subtree rooted with node i which is an
index in array arr
and n is the size of the heap
so void
heapify
i
now we will initialize largest as root
so end
largest
is equals to i
now we will define the left and the
right subtree so end
l is equals to
2
into i
plus one
and
end
r is equals to
two multiply
with i
plus
two now if the left child is larger than
root
then if
l is less than n
and arr
at l
error at l is greater than arr at
largest
so
the largest
will be equals to l
now if
right child is larger than the largest
so far
so if
r
is less than n
and
arr at r
is greater than arr
at largest
so largest
is equals to r
now if largest is not root so if
largest
is not equals to i
we will swap
arr
at i
with
a arr
at largest
and then we will recursively call ep5
for the affected
subtree error comma
and
comma largest
now we will write the main function to
do heap sort
so void
deep sort
and
arr
bracket comma
and
n
now we will start by building heap
so for
and
i is equals to
n by 2
minus 1
where i is greater than equals to 0
at i minus minus
we will call heapify
for a r comma n comma i
now we will one by one extract an
element from the heap
so for
and i
is equals to n minus 1
where i is greater than 0
at i minus minus
now we will move current root to end so
swap
error
at zero
to ar
at i
and we will call max episode on the
reduced heap so he p5
error
comma i
comma
zero
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
and array
and
arr
comma and n
so for
and
i is equals to zero
i less than n
plus plus i
we will do c out
arr
bracket i
is
and a c out
and l
now let's write the code for the main
block
so
second
arr
is equals to
3 comma
18 comma 12
comma
14 comma
5 comma 6
comma
2
now we will write a statement to find
the size of this array so end
and it's equals to
size of
arr
divided
by size of
the first element of the array
arr0
now we will call heap sort function so
heap sort
for arr
comma n
now let's print this
array so c out
sorted
array
is
print
array
at arr comma n
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see our sorting function is
working flawlessly
let's get started with what exactly is
divide and conquer algorithm
a divide and conquer algorithm
iteratively divides a problem into two
or more sub problems of the same or
relative type until they are simple
enough to be solved directly the
subproblem solutions are then integrated
to solve the original problem
there are three steps involved in the
divide and conquer principle that is
divide
conquer and combine
the first step is to divide the
significant problem into smaller sub
problems
the second phase is to conquer the
solutions to all divided sub problems
then the final step is to combine and
merge all of the solutions to create a
definite solution
we will understand this by an example
right here on my screen
suppose we have a large problem we can
use divide and conquer technique to
divide it into n number of sub problems
such as problem 1 problem 2 problem 3
problem 4 and so on until we reach the
problem n
then we conquer all the solutions to the
specified sub problems as solution 1 2 3
4 and so on and finally we match all the
solutions to get one definitive solution
now that was divide and conquer
algorithm followed by that let us get
into merge sort algorithm
so merge sort is one of the most
efficient sorting algorithms it is based
on divide and conquer strategy merge
sort continuously divides a list into
numerous sub-list until each sub-list
contains only one entry then merges all
those sub-list into a sorted list
there are four elements on my screen
we have 7 and 3 in the left half and 5
and 2 in the right half after dividing
the four elements in half we combined
all the items in ascending order that is
2 3 5 and 7.
in the next segment we are going to
understand how it happened and we are
going to learn the working procedure of
merge sort algorithm
there are two approaches to implement
the merge sort algorithm the first
method is top down approach and the
second method is bottoms-up approach the
first method that is the top-down
approach implies that it begins with the
large picture from then it's broken into
smaller chunks
now the second method that is the
bottom-up technique which starts with a
specific number of jobs and works its
way up to the general
let's have a look at how to implement
the merchant algorithm using top-down
approach the top-down merge sort
approach is the methodology that uses a
recursion mechanism it starts at the top
and proceeds downwards splitting the
array into two halves making a recursive
call and merging the results until one
gets to the bottom of the array for a
better understanding of the top down
approach method
consider the following scenario right
here on my screen we have an example of
an array of size 6 consisting of
elements 7 3 9 5 6 and 4. starting with
0 and ending with 5.
using the following formula we'll divide
the array by its middle that is middle
is equals to left plus right divided by
2.
we have 3 elements on the left and three
elements on the right near the middle so
according to the drop down strategy we
divide the given array in half resulting
in three elements that is 7 3 and 9 on
the left and 5 6 and 4 on the right next
we sort all these elements in ascending
order by doing so the first half will be
3 7 and 9 and the right half will be 4 5
and 6 and after merging all of them we
will have the sorted array that is three
four five six and nine
next we will understand the bottom sub
approach
an iterative process is used in bottoms
up merge sort approach it starts with a
single element array and then joins two
neighboring items while also sorting
them the combined sorted arrays are
combined and sorted again only until one
single unit of the sorted array elements
remains
now let us look at an example right here
on my screen in the first iteration we
will merge pairs of array sizes by 1
sorting each of the 2 elements
when you iterate the array by size 1 the
elements 7 and three become three and
seven similarly nine and five become
five and nine and finally six and four
become four and six
we will merge the pairs of array size by
two in the next iteration with the
bottoms up method as a result the
elements 3 7 and 5 will become 3 5 and 7
and the same way 9 4 and 6 will become 4
6 and 9.
in the last iteration merge pairs of
array size by 3 so that after sorting 3
5 7 4 6 and 9 becomes 3 4 5 6 and 7 as
sorted arrays
after understanding the working
procedure of merge cert algorithm we
will now see the pseudo code of merge
sort algorithm
we have a function called merge sort in
this pseudo code and parameter of the
function contains an array named as
array and two variables named as left
and right
if the number of elements in the left is
greater than the number of elements on
the right we will get a middle using
formula left plus right divided by 2.
the merge sort is called and this
function
now has an array a left variable and
right variable by calling merge sort we
have array left as middle plus one and
right variable and finally by calling
merge sort we have left middle and right
variables in our upcoming segment we
will implement the merge sort method in
a practical demonstration
in the next section we will discuss the
complexity of merge sort algorithm
first we will look into the time
complexity of merge sort algorithm as we
all know time complexity in data
structures is divided into best case
average case and worst case the best
case of merced algorithm is big o of n
into log n average case of merced
algorithm is big o of n into log n and
the worst case of merced algorithm is
big o of n into log n
the number of elements being sorted is
given by n merge sorts time complexity
is big o of n star log n in all three
situations that has worst average and
best because it always divides the array
into two halves and merges the two
halves in linear time
it takes up the same amount of space as
the unsorted array as a result it is not
a good idea to use it to search big
unsorted arrays moving on to the space
complexity of the merced algorithm the
space complexity of the merge sort
algorithm is large o of n
in the merced algorithm we store the
left and right parts of the merged array
in the temporary arrays and then utilize
the original array to keep the entire
merged array in the worst case scenario
the left and the right sub arrays will
each be n by 2 in size and then the
total auxiliary space will be big o of n
resulting in a space complexity of big o
of n
following that we will look into several
applications of the merge sort algorithm
so the first application is merge sort
is an efficient way to sort linked list
in big o of n log n time
subsequent application of the merge sort
algorithm is for linked lists merge
sought implemented without taking up
more space followed by that the mod
start method is used to count the number
of inversions in a list
last application states that in internal
sorting the merge sort is employed
now let us look into some of the
drawbacks of merge sort algorithm
so some of the drawbacks of merge sort
algorithm are for smaller assignments
merge sort algorithm is slower than the
other sorting algorithms for temporary
array the merge sort technique requires
an additional memory space that is space
of big o of n
now let us look into a practical
demonstration of merge sort algorithm on
my screen we have an example for merge
sort algorithm
to define constants or micro
substitution we use the hash defined as
preprocessor directive with a constant
variable max of 10. following that two
arrays array 1 and array 2 are declared
we declare array 1 and initialize it
with elements like 8 4
4 and 1
array 2 is used for temporary array then
to implement the merge sort concept we
declare a merge sort function we specify
three variables in this function
parameter that is left right and middle
the left variable is used to display the
left part of the array one the right
variable is used to display the right
part of the array1 and middle variable
is used to indicate the middle or center
of the array in this function
we utilize the for loop in this function
setting the left 2 level 1 the middle
plus 1 to level 2 and
the left to variable i with the
condition that level 2 is less than or
equal to the middle and level 2 should
be less than or equal to the right of
the array
we have a condition in this for loop
that if level 1 of array 1 is less than
or equal to level 2 of array 1 we will
initialize all the consecutive elements
of level 1 of array 1 to array 2. else
we will initialize all the successive
elements of level 2 of array 1 to array
2.
out of for loop all subsequent elements
of level 1 of array 1 will be
initialized to array 2 until level 1 is
less than or equal to the middle all
successive elements of level 2 of array
1 will be initialized to array 2 until
level 2 is less than or equal to the
right of the array
using the loop which will run from i
equal to the left of i is less than or
equal to right we initialize all the
items of array 2 to array 1. we have
declared one more function in this code
namely sorting out of the merging sort
function in which only the left and
right variables are defined we specified
the middle function in the sorting
function with the condition that if the
left is less than the right the middle
will be calculated as left plus right
divided by 2. then we call the sorting
function passing left as middle as right
and then another sorting function
passing left as middle plus one and
right
finally we use the merge sort function
passing left middle and right to the
sorting array one otherwise we will
return nothing
we entered the main function out of the
sorting function where we declared the
counter variable i and printed the array
before sorting using the printf function
in for loop
where i will run from index 0 to the
array's maximum size after that we
invoked sorting method
passing left as 0 index number and write
as the iris maximum value finally after
doing the merge sort process we will
print the array using the printf
function and for loop
we will run
from 0 to the array's maximum value then
we compile the program and run it
now let's try to quickly execute this
program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the list
before sorting is eight seven six two
three five nine ten four and one and the
list after sorting is one two three four
4 5 6 7 8 9 and 10. let's get started
with an introduction to selection sort
the selection sort algorithm is an
in-place comparison based method that
divides the list into two halves with
the sorted portion on the left and the
unsorted half on the right
then the smallest element from the
unsorted array is chosen and swapped
with the leftmost element and that
element is added to the sorted error
now let's discuss the selection sort
algorithm
let's say we have an array
first we will divide this array in two
sub-arrays unsorted array and sorted
array
then we will divide the minimum element
from the unsorted array and swap it with
the leftmost element of this unsorted
array after that we will add it to the
unsorted array
we will keep repeating this process
until there are no elements left on the
unsorted
array
we have now introduced
selection sort and its algorithm
now let's implement this algorithm in
the code editor
we will start by creating a function
swap
argument will be integer pointer
x comma
integer pointer
y
you will declare an element temp to
store the value of
pointer x
then we will store pointer wise value in
x
and we will store temps value in y
and that's how we can swap them
next we will write the definition of
selection sort function
void
selection sort
its argument will be
end
array arr
comma
and
n
we will declare variables and i
j
and a min
underscore idx
variable to store the minimum index
now we will one by one move boundaries
of unsorted sub arrays so for loop
i is equals to 0
where i is less than n minus 1
i plus plus
we will find the minimum element in this
unsorted array so
min
underscore
idx
is equals to i
now for
a is equals to
i plus 1
j less than n
j plus plus
if
array element at j location
is less than
array at the min index
then
min idx
will be updated with j
now we will swap the form minimum
element with the first element
so
we will call swap function
with argument as
ampersand
arr
at min idx
comma
ampersand
arr
at ith location
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
array
argument as int arr
and its size
and n
whole loop
and i is equals to 0
i less than
n
i plus plus
v out
arr
at i
layout
and l
now we will write the code for the main
block
so end
arr
is equals to
4 comma 2 comma 1 comma 8 comma 3
we will find the size of this array so
end n is equals to
size of
array arr
divided by size of
this arrays first element
now we will call selection sort function
argument as arr comma n
then we will try to print this so c out
sorted
array
and we will call the function print
array
to print this array
arr comma n
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using selection sort
algorithm let's get started with an
introduction to shell sort
shell sort is a sorting algorithm that
is based on insertion sort algorithm and
it is very efficient when the smaller
value is on the far right and must be
shifted to the far left then this method
avoids significant shifts as in
insertion sort
now let's discuss the algorithm of shell
sort
let's say we have an array we will
initialize a variable h
this h will represent intervals
then we will divide this array into h
intervals it will create some sub arrays
then we will apply insertion sort on
these sub arrays
after that we will reduce the interval
edge by 1
then we will repeat this process
recursively until h counts down to 1.
we have now introduced shell sort and
its algorithm now let's try to implement
this algorithm in the code editor
first we will start within function to
sort an array using shell sort
so int
cell sort
we will write argument as int
arr
bracket
comma
and n
we will start with a big interval then
we will reduce this interval by one
so
for loop
and
interval
equals to n by two
interval
greater than 0
and interval
divide equals to 2.
now we will do a gap insertion sort for
this interval
so for
and i is equals to interval
i is less than n
i plus equals to 1.
and
amp
is equals to
ar packet i
now we will shift earlier gap sorted
element up until the correct location
for arr i is for
so and
a
so for
k is equals to i
and j greater than equals to interval
and and
arr bracket
j minus interval
greater than temp
and j minus equals to
interval
now arr
at
j is equals to arr
j minus
interval
now we will put this stamp
in its correct location so arr
bracket j
is equals to
temp
now i will return zero
now let's write a function to print this
array
so void
print
array
so for
loop
and
j is equals to zero
a less than
n
j plus plus
c out
arr
bracket j
now we will write the function for the
main block
so end
arr
is equals to
12 comma 34
comma
56 comma
85 comma
2 comma
9
comma 11.
comma
five
now
let's find the size for this array so
int n
is equals to
size of
array
divided by
size of
first element of this array
now
see out
array
array
before
sort
a print
array
arr comma
and
i'll sort
error comma n
now c out
erase
after
sorting
we will again print array
here comma m
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted
this array
here we will look into the real life
example of greedy algorithm in order to
understand it better this is alex he's
quite wealthy and intelligent as he
works for one of the most reputed it
firms and this is alex's best friend
rachel rachel is in dire need of 85
right now
however she needs money in such a
quantity that the number of coins is
kept to a minimum so rachel shared this
issue with alex and asked him for help
now alex is thinking about rachel's
issue which he can easily fix because he
has a limitless supply of 50
ten dollars and five dollar coins
stashed in various bags
although this being said alex needed to
think about the constraint rachel told
him about he needed to give her money
such that the number of coins utilized
must be minimal
to do so alex began making a list of the
various coin combinations in which he
could present money to rachel however
after a while he became confused due to
the vast number of conceivable
combinations
so he decided to use his programming
ability to solve real life problems
alex developed a program that will
provide him with the optimal number of
coins that he can present to rachel
this generated program was iterating
through the different possibilities to
choose the best solution
at each iteration the program added the
coin of the largest value that was not
taking alex past the amount to be paid
which is 85 in this case
for eighty-five dollars the largest
denomination id can start giving is
fifty dollars
now id is still short of thirty five
dollars to reach the amount so that the
next largest coin program can take in as
twenty dollars
but since the program still requires
fifteen dollars to meet the threshold
the next highest denomination it can
accept is ten dollars followed by five
dollars
the best part about this program was
that it allowed alex to present
eighty-five dollars in just four coins
which is fairly incredible
the vital thing to note here is that
after each loop the program makes a
greedy choice providing the coin with
the highest potential value what i mean
here by greedy is that locally optimal
choice is picked at every step to reach
the global optimum solution now moving
ahead we will formulate the idea of
greedy algorithms
basically a greedy algorithm is based on
a problem-solving method that involves
making locally optimal decisions at each
stage in the hopes of achieving a global
optimum
that means at each stage we choose a
locally optimal value in the hopes of
arriving at the optimum possible end
result
furthermore this algorithm is an
optimization technique that can find
either minimum optimum result or maximum
optimum result
the best part about this algorithm is
that it is simple to understand and
implement as well additionally the
runtime complexity for this algorithm is
pretty reasonable
however the fundamental disadvantage of
this strategy is that we only receive
the globally optimum value in a small
percentage of cases
having said that you must be thinking
about when to implement this algorithm
for solving particular problems as it
does not always produce globally optimum
results
well let me tell you guys that we have
two conditions to judge our problem for
implementing greedy algorithms
the first condition is the greedy choice
property this notion states that making
locally optimal judgments can lead to
the global optimum solution for a given
problem
the second condition is about optimal
substructure the problem has an optimal
substructure only if an optimal solution
to the entire problem comprises the
optimal solutions to the subproblems
in simpler words that means the problem
can be split down into multiple
sub-problems and the solutions to these
sub-problems can collectively lead to a
solution for the entire problem
if both the above-mentioned properties
are satisfied by the problem then we can
create a greedy solution for that
particular problem
moving forward we will look into the
steps for constructing a greedy solution
finding the substructure or sub problem
that can lead us to the final answer is
the first step in building a greedy
algorithm
because in this algorithm we are just
trying to operate with local optima to
reach the global optimum solution
the second step is about determining the
type of solution the given problem can
result into that can be either the
largest sum or minimum path
the final step for creating the greedy
solution is about creating an iterative
process for traversing through local
stages and making decisions to reach a
globally optimum solution
now you might be confused about how we
can do that
well let's go through an example to
understand the approach to implement a
greedy solution
the example that we are going to deal
with is called the traveling salesman
problem in which a salesman is supposed
to reach the destination from a given
current location
the representation of cities and parts
connecting them is done using graph
structure where each node is considered
as a city and edges connecting them as
parts having edge weight as the distance
between the two cities
now in this case we are supposed to find
the minimum path between two cities so
to do that we will begin from the
current arbitrary position
from this node called as starting
location there are three possible paths
but the path towards city b has less
distance hence we will traverse this
edge primarily as it is an optimal local
route
we have reached city b now and from this
node we have two possible parts out of
which one part directly leads us towards
the destination city having distance 20
but the other path leading towards the
city f has edge weight value or distance
value as two
hence according to the local optimal
decision we will choose the edge
connecting cities b and f for traversal
we have reached the city f now from this
node or city there is only one path
leading us to our destination
hence we will traverse it now we have
reached the destination city the path
highlighted in the green shade is the
global optimum for this tsp problem you
can verify that by calculating the edge
weights for all other possible parts
since the solution allows us to reach
the global optimum by making optimal
decisions at the local stage this
strategy to solve the problem will be
considered a greedy approach
now moving ahead we will look into the
demerits of using greedy algorithm
we have learnt that the greedy algorithm
makes decisions based on local optimum
instead of analyzing the broader picture
of the whole data hence there is a
possibility that the greedy solution
might not be the best optimal solution
for some problems
for example consider this travelling
salesman problem
in this problem the highlighted part is
a created solution to reach the
destination city from the current
location using a greedy algorithm
but if you observe this graph the
selected solution is not the global
optimal solution for this problem
in contrast it is the worst generated
solution to reach the destination
that is why the greedy algorithm is
considered to be prone to correctness
issues
even if the algorithm is correct proving
why it is correct is difficult thus it
is deemed to be trickier to solve
specific issues
now we will discuss about applications
of greedy algorithms to understand their
importance
the first application of a greedy
algorithm is its use for constructing
minimum spanning trees
the coding approaches that we use to
generate msds is based on the greedy
algorithm
both prim's algorithm and kruskal's
algorithm are known as greedy algorithms
as they make decisions based on locally
optimal decisions
the next application of the greedy
algorithm is it's used to implement
huffman encoding and decoding algorithms
the huffman coding technique is a
lossless data compression method
the concept is to give variable length
codes to input characters the lengths of
which are determined by the frequency of
the related characters
the smallest code is assigned to the
most frequently occurring character
whereas the largest code is assigned to
the least frequently occurring character
this process is carried out by making
local optimum decisions
hence it is also considered to be a
greedy algorithm
the final application of the greedy
algorithm is its use for developing
solutions to well-known coding problems
those problems are the activity
selection problem
job selection problem and fractional
knapsack problem
all these problems generate solutions by
making decisions at each local stage so
the solutions for these problems can be
developed quite easily using the greedy
approach
so this was all for today's session i
hope this session was informative and
interesting if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you need the code for
all the coding algorithms discussed in
this particular tutorial then please
feel free to let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be happy to resolve all your
queries until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
you